les élections régionales ont lieu tous
les six ans selon un mode de scrutin
proportionnel de liste à deux tours avec
prime majoritaire c'est à dire que si
une liste obtient plus de 50% des
suffrages exprimés
elle obtient immédiatement un quart des
sièges disponibles
les autres sièges sont répartis
proportionnellement entre toutes les
listes qui ont obtenu au moins 5% des
suffrages exprimés dans ce cas là il n'y
a qu'un seul tour de scrutin
mais si aucune liste n'obtient la
majorité absolue un second tour est
organisé pour y participer une liste
doit recueillir au moins 10% des
suffrages exprimés
celles ayant obtenu au moins 5 % peuvent
fusionner avec celle qui se maintiennent
le scrutin et régionales mais la liste
déposée présente les candidats par
section départementale c'est à dire
concrètement qu'un électeur yvelinois et
un électeur estoniens qui appartiennent
à la même région voteront pour des
candidats différents
mais une tête de liste est désigné pour
l'ensemble de la région le nombre de
sièges attribués à chaque liste est
calculé au niveau de la région
mais au sein de chaque liste les sièges
sont attribués par sections
départementales
prenons un exemple si la liste d'un
candidat arrive en tête au niveau
régional alors ses conseillers régionaux
obtiendront des sièges en fonction des
suffrages obtenus dans chaque
département pour la région ile de france
ils sont onze candidats à se présenter
les listes doivent être paritaires il
doit y avoir autant d'hommes et de
femmes sur la même liste